do you have advice for people who suffer
from mild forms of depression
or feel
as they might
both for those people and do you have
advice for people
who
love the people who suffer from
depression and want to help yeah
one of the incredibly
frustrating things about depression is
the very nature of it
makes it hard for the people who suffer
to
get treatment because they they're
hopeless so they don't think treatment
will help they have low energy
so they're not motivated to participate
in treatment in many cases
they're sometimes they're actively
suicidal that certainly doesn't help
they have all these things that
seem to prevent
treatment from being effective so the
loved ones that's where the loved ones
are so important is is helping them
overcome these barriers to treatment the
motivation the safety
uh and the insight
that's critical uh
and particularly for the severe cases
for the mild cases where people still
have you know
have some insight and motivation and and
energy to get something done
there are many things you can do uh
exercise is extremely important in in
mood maintenance
regulation of sleep and getting
sufficient and regular enough sleep is
very important
and talk therapy can be helpful in those
mild or moderate cases just looking at
cognitions looking at patterns of
thought
that
people may have fallen into
where they catastrophize where they
spiral from small things into big things
a little bit of talk therapy 10 12
sessions can help people identify
those patterns they may have in
themselves
that are
taking
occasional negative thoughts which
everybody has
and magnifying those into
more persistent negative states
once you if you work at this it's kind
of like homework this is what we call
cognitive behavioral therapy
it's very structured very organized you
work hard it requires insight and
motivation and you have to be
motivated
but if you are then you can identify
these triggers that send you down
particular pathways and work to
intercept them and that is
amazingly very effective in mild to
moderate cases so you basically
have to train yourself to see the world
as a
collection of triggers
and you have to first understand like
collect the data
like basically see every experience
as a thing that creates a follow-on
emotion of feeling
and like i've learned this
you know like on social media
where like early on
you know like all of us
um you know i'll i'll say something
i kind of respond to negativity
with negativity
and then you observe
the results of that
over time
you think wait a minute
the this thing that i've been doing
where when somebody says you suck and
you say no you suck
that never produces the result you
thought it might
and so might not want to just
don't say you suck back
and i do this through a lot of things in
life
i'm very fortunate to
not suffer from uh depression but
i uh first of all i have
had and have people in my life who do
and and also you know all of us
have depression who don't suffer from
depression have depression out
like it's always knocking on the door
right yeah
and so you you have mild uh
i mean uh
if you're very careless with the
triggers
all around you
then you
you're just i think all of us have the
capacity to really suffer
uh from that kind of
uh chemical or psychological or
philosophical existential crisis
but then it raises a question why are we
built this way it seems like it doesn't
make sense right um and here's where
some of this thinking about where we
came from
uh
as the human family is is kind of
interesting
does it make sense that somewhere on
that spectrum
that it's good to detect that there's an
array of
adverse forces out there in the world
right now at this moment
and to withdraw
to
to hunker down
to not fight not strive not try to meet
the challenge
and
outweigh
these
negative forces that are present out
there and that makes a lot of sense
uh
and all animals that have been studied
in one form or another show this even
the worm that i mentioned earlier
c elegans with 302 neurons
it can effectively give up in
challenging situations we've done this
with zebrafish tiny little transparent
fish
you can give them a challenging
situation and they
will give up but then if you
stimulate a couple very specific brain
regions in particular ways you can
motivate them to overcome the challenge
and if you inhibit those regions they
give up much more easily than they would
otherwise you can do this in mice you
can do this in rats
so this is an ancestral conserved
pattern to detect
that things are
pretty bad out there
and to conserve energy
to hunker down to wait out the storm
says use unfortunately
many of our maladies have
useful roots in in our
uh like contribute to our survival so
both depression and motivation
have uses
and in the pain sometimes it's nice to
just
shut the hell up and huddle with the
penguins
right uh versus
for some unknown reason venture out on
your own into the mountains like a david
goggins type character
you